President Biden continues to push for
reinstatement of the assault weapons ban
that Congress LED expire back in 2004
but with Republicans in control of the
house that's looking very unlikely
more big news from Washington as
senators from both parties voted
yesterday to end the open-ended
authorization that had allowed the U.S
to wage war in Iraq for much of the last
two decades it's a move that's been
years in the making and what's happening
is Congress is trying to reassert its
own authority to declare war as Scott
McFarland reports it comes with a strong
backing of some of the veterans who
served in Iraq
yeah
more than 20 years after America began
its bombing in Iraq the bill has passed
Senators passed a landmark Bill
Wednesday
which officially repeals the
authorization for a war which toppled
Saddam Hussein led to the deaths of
thousands of U.S service members the
wounding of tens of thousands more and
from which America removed fighting
forces a dozen years ago this is
obviously very important to me
personally Democratic senator Tim Kaine
whose son as a marine has spent nearly a
decade fighting for this legislation and
joined forces with Republicans to do it
these authorizations are outdated
they're a detriment to our national
security strategy
and they're an abdication of congress's
constitutional role and declaring and
yes ending wars in the course of the
Iraq War
um I lost not one but two buddies I wear
a bracelet every day on my wrist to
remember one of them Army veteran
Allison jaslow says the vote is
important to ensure Congress acts as a
check and doesn't rush in or out of
future conflicts it is more than
anything else
um a great service to those who are
wearing the uniform today and their
families
um because they are the ones who are
playing their lives on the line and and
they deserve
a thoughtful debate but the vote wasn't
unanimous with some Senators worried it
sends the wrong message this repeal will
only add fuel to the narrative that the
US is disengaging from the region
Senator Kane argued the decision to go
to war in 2002 was rushed based on
intelligence about weapons of mass
destruction that was false another
reason for Congress to reassert its
powers it's unclear when this issue will
get to the U.S house floor but speaker
Kevin McCarthy says earlier this month
there's a good chance it gets to the
floor Gail
hmm all right Scott thank you very much